I been I'm Frank brown from insead and a
great question you asked I think the key
to successful change involving youth is
to fully engage and we actually had a
conversation about this this morning in
one of the sessions I was in because the
point was a lot of the developments in
the world are being driven by very young
people particularly as people become
more and more engaged with technology at
a very very young age and the challenge
for my generation and even the
generation between mine and sort of 10
year old set is to effectively involve
younger people in the development of
things are going to change and then
thinking about your point with respect
to climate change which is even more
specific I think that governments have
to get a much more active program of
creating opportunities for voice among
young people and I think the electorate
be elected officials around the world
are starting to recognize that starting
miracle focus groups etc so hopefully
the solution is not at hand but people
are starting to realize what the problem
is and and start to create solutions so
good locker